[Música]
comenzamos el espacio de medio ambiente
aquí en france24 yo soy maría clara
calle y les doy la bienvenida y
empezamos hablando de desperdicios de
ropa a ghana en áfrica llegan cada día
millones de toneladas de prendas usadas
que provienen de países del norte global
la cantidad de estándar que allí se
reutiliza hasta 25 veces más pantalones
y camisas que en los mercados de segunda
mano de eeuu pero casi la mitad termina
siendo basura que se tira a los océanos
o se quema y las consecuencias las
padecen los habitantes de la capital del
país africano por eso algunas
organizaciones hablan de una política
colonialista y piden reducir la
producción textil para frenar también
los impactos climáticos veamos
la ropa se produce un ritmo frenético y
ningún otro país padece tanto las
consecuencias de esto como ghana en la
capital accra está el que quizás es el
mercado de segunda mano más grande del
mundo
acan está manto llegan 15 millones de
prendas usadas cada semana el 40%
termina siendo desechada para hacerse
una idea esto es hasta 70 toneladas cada
día de prendas que se convierten en
basura ni gana ni su capital tienen como
procesar tantos desperdicios desde anda
y termina el fast fashion la sobra
oferta de la economía lineal aquí es
donde nuestros excesos se sienten va al
ambiente llega al océano millones de
prendas terminan en el fondo del océano
en accra
y otros tantos van a las canaletas
cuando la ropa las obstruye aumenta el
riesgo de malaria y de cólera para los
habitantes mientras que montañas de
desperdicios textiles de hasta 20 metros
de alto se queman lo que pone en riesgo
la vida de los habitantes ante los
tóxicos que se liberan si bien en países
productores como reino unido canadá o
eeuu hay tiendas de segunda mano para
vender la ropa de reciclada allí se
comercializa tan sólo el 20 por ciento
el resto va a dar a países del sur
global como gana francia por ejemplo
hace que las grandes marcas paguen
impuestos para gestionar sus desechos
pero ese dinero es ínfimo y muchas veces
no llega a los lugares donde tiran sus
basuras ante el problema existen
organizaciones como dior fundation que
buscan alternativas al sistema de moda
actual
esta política es esencialmente una
política colonialista de desperdicios
necesitamos presionar por reformas para
asegurar que si las prendas siguen
llegando a países como ghana primero
reconozcamos que no es una forma real de
manejar los residuos sólo es exportarlo
no es una solución y segundo tenemos que
el dinero viaje con la ropa si las
prendas siguen llegando a ganar el
dinero también debería llegar para
financiar infraestructura local para la
economía circular es
otra de las soluciones que propone una
activista de la economía circular en la
moda es que los gobiernos le pongan un
freno a la producción frenética y el
objetivo es reducir el impacto ecológico
de la moda y para eso frenar el modelo
económico de la fast fashion entonces en
este sentido las dos pedimos a los
gobiernos que pongan legislación para de
favorecer el modelo económico de la fast
fashion y hasta que esto se haga las
montañas de ropa se siguen acumulando en
gana
y de áfrica nos vamos a europa porque
londres tiene el potencial de ser líder
contra la crisis climática esto es lo
que quiere resaltar la semana de las
acciones del cambio climático en la
capital inglesa que se realiza esta
semana empresarios políticos activistas
y también académicos y ongs participan
en más de 170 eventos para discutir como
la ciudad inglesa puede alcanzar las
cero emisiones netas de carbono por eso
en el evento el alcalde londinense
sadik khan anunció que firmó el tratado
de no proliferación de combustibles
fósiles una iniciativa global que ya han
suscrito 52 ciudades y gobiernos
subnacionales además de 1300
organizaciones y 150.000 individuos de
todo el mundo como prueba de las
intenciones el metro de londres
trabajará con energía renovable nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido fue al evento
y tiene toda la información de lo que
allí ocurrió
en la semana de acciones contra el
cambio climático en londres que ha
reunido expertos académicos miembros de
la sociedad civil el alcalde de londres
david kahn anunció la firma de el
acuerdo de no proliferación de
combustibles fósiles es decir que en
londres se une a este importante tratado
para acabar con la proliferación de este
tipo de combustibles para acabar con la
dependencia de estos combustibles por
ello el metro de londres empezará a
utilizar energía ciento por ciento
renovable más verde energía eólica
energía solar se iniciará con un 10 por
ciento hasta llegar a esa meta de todo
el funcionamiento del método de londres
que es uno de los iconos de la ciudad
sea completamente verde pero el alcalde
de londres también ha dicho que la
ciudad está caminando está dando los
pasos importantes para lograr cumplir
esa meta de la producción de cero
gases de efecto invernadero para el 2030
shadi khan también has insistido en la
importancia del trabajo de gobiernos
locales municipales y nacionales para
lograr efectos y acciones que
contribuyan contra esta emergencia del
cambio climático que no solo azota a
europa por ejemplo hemos visto en días
recientes olas de calor en todo el
continente sino también en todo el mundo
y con estas informaciones de ghana y de
londres despedimos nuestra crónica de
medio ambiente los invitamos a que vean
este encima de nuestros programas en
france24 punto com y en nuestro canal de
youtube nos vemos en una próxima ocasión
[Música]